etiquettes of speaking or how
the prophet spoke, how he used
words so forth. This is kind of
the theme of these chapters
here. We discussed last week
and then, May you send no
When I walk far
[Silence]
then last week We discussed
what is the for a person to do
during, right? What should a
person do during a then? What
should they say, How should
they repeat after them? We have
an issue that we'd to
discuss and that is the that is
recorded, recorded it then,
on your phone, right? Some
apps, most apps, they have, you
know, the it calls the either a
portion of it or all of it on
the time of salah and then,
we'll also call the Ikama,
right? people often are
confused about this event. What
is the ruling on this event? To
the point that some people will
feel a kind of they will feel
discouraged to turn off the
event when it's being called on
the phone. Even if they're in
salah. Sometimes even here in
the Masjid we have people that
have their phone you know, set
to make a then at a certain
time and when the event is
going off on their phone or
during a funeral or something
that, they will feel
reluctant to turn this off or
to silence it, right? So, what
is the ruling of this? The
answer is and then has no
ruling because it's not
considered a then
legislatively, right? It's a
then has to have intention A
person has to have intention to
make a then. So, for instance,
if we were to teach a parrot,
teach a parrot that at every
time, every day at this time or
that time, you make it then,
right? Would this be valid? You
know, for the town. We have a
parrot making it then instead
of a human or now, we have, we
have you know, recordings. Is
it okay for us to have the
recording time to make a then
for us, right? So the recording
makes an end for the whole
town. No no more because it's
recorded. What's the answer?
No. This would not be valid.
Why? Because a then has to be a
conscious decision made by the
collective with an intention.
And they you know, the
collective, the community, they
decide on a particular person
to do this thing that is
wedging for them on their
behalf. So, it then has to have
intention. There's an
interaction between them and
the person who hears the event
and that has to be driven by
intention on both sides. So,
what is the ruling of the that
is recorded on a person's
phone? The answer is it has no
ruling. It has no ruling. It's
not considered a then. You do
not repeat after it. You do not
make dua after it, right? And
you do not, you do not use it
instead of nor does it take the
place of making a in your house
for instance. Persons in their
house, there's no masjid nearby
that makes an end. They need to
make it then for their salah.
They need to make if your phone
calls the does that count? No,
it does not count. If the
starts going off in an
inappropriate time, should a
person silence it? Yes,
immediately silence it. Persons
in a funeral, persons in all
the sudden, we have three four,
10 phones, started making, and
then. Also, we have this going
on when the event is actually
being made. So, as the starts
making Adan, everybody's phone
starts going off, right? Or for
instance, we're giving a class
now and we stop maybe a minute
or two after the time of it
then. So, while I'm giving the
class, all the phones start
going off and making it in.
This is inappropriate, right?
We have to have a person to
make a then for us. But
Another issue
Amran Amil Adan, Lee Attenbi,
Hala Sola.
[Silence]
In mosques here in this Masjid.
Is set. It's always at 110,
always. No matter what day of
the year it is, it's always
going to be at one 10. And the
is always going to be at one
o'clock. Sometimes, comes in at
11 something, right? So the
question is, should the be
made? At the time, when the
time of the salah comes in, or
should it be made for the
occasion of the salah? The
answer is a man should be made
for the occasion of salah. So,
Adan follows salah. It doesn't
follow the time. Sometimes, you
know, our previous schedule was
we would make Aisha no earlier
than eight o'clock at night
here in this Masjid, right? But
sometimes in the winter, it's
time starts at five, 515, 530,
right? So, do we make a then at
530 and then three hours later,
make a karma? No. Because a
then goes with salah. It
doesn't go with it doesn't go
with the time. Usually, it's
made on time. But it depends on
what the community for that
local mosque, that locale, what
they have agreed upon. And
whatever times they have agreed
upon to make salah and then
follows the time of salah. It
doesn't follow the time when
salah is valid. This is how the
prophet would make an end. This
is how you'd use it for the
occasion of salah. So, we see
for instance, when the prophet
you know, this is narrations in
Bukhari and elsewhere. When we
see that the prophet would be
traveling. Right? He'd be
traveling. He would not make a
then until it was time for
salah. Meaning when he would
make salah. So, you're
traveling comes in at 12
o'clock. You don't make to one
30. Adan needs to be made at
one thirty, right? So, I then
follow salah and it doesn't
necessarily follow. The time of
salat. This is the most correct
opinion of the with regards to
this issue. Another issue of
does a person repeat after the
and
or only the event.
[Silence]
and then is used to refer to
the and it's also used to refer
to the so he says between every
two and then there is two raka
to be made for those who wish
to do so. Right? So he says
between every two and then
right? So, the in the of the
prophet if it is mentioned just
it is used to refer to both and
however, if he says the word
then is used to in the same
sentence, then, Adan is
obviously Adan and is to mark
the beginning of the prayer
immediately. We mentioned last
week the
Hams, Sunan, You send no.
You are
[Silence]
they repeat after them and then
exactly what the Moed then
says. Except when he says or in
this case you say,
likewise, we said in the you
repeat after the
what should you say? Or in the
morning if he says what should
you say?
[Silence]
The second Sunnah is that after
the Shahada
he said it the last time you
say
[Silence]
at least that we say Allah
Muhammad at least but whenever
we find in the that the prophet
says to make upon him what is
meant and the best way of
making salah is to say what we
say in salah. Allah
In Majid.
I
[Silence]
prophet. There's a particular
dua to make That dua is
[Silence]
those who make dua, right?
What's the best dua a person
should make? Well, mentions
here in the narration which he
states is authentic. He says,
that the companions asked the
prophet after he informed them
supplication, dua, prayer will
not be rejected between so they
asked him, so what should we
say? What's the best thing to
say? He said, ask Allah for
pardon. In this life and the
hereafter. Persons say
aluminium
Just that. Alright?
Abdul the
[Silence]
he encouraged that a person
make plenty of saying and
[Arabic recitation]
Alhamdulillah during this time.
And it's mentioned that of his
that during the month of the he
would begin specific beer. So,
all of the first 10 days of the
were making general all the
time. Doesn't, it's not
specific for the time of salah.
However, when we get to the
ninth day which is the day of
Arafah, he would begin to make
specific tekbir after each
salah So, every time you made a
salah, finish finisher,
starting on the day of of the
ninth day which is the day of
Arafah and that specific Taqbir
after every salah will be the
five prayers will be until
until
of the thirteenth day. because
we have the day of Arafah, we
have the day of Obha, and then
we have 3 days for right? The
days of so, during, you know
the we have a very long Eid
which begins at at Arafa and it
ends on the thirteenth. It
begins on the ninth and is on
the thirteenth. So we are
making Tekbir specifically
after each prayer of the five
daily prayers and if there is a
during that time. We're making
it when after
every starting at on the ninth
day and ending after on the
thirteenth day of the Hajja.
I'm saying this a lot and I'm
repeating myself over and over
and over. Why? Because a lot of
people confuse this. Now, what
about the Eid? Eid al Futr.
Ramadan. Eid Ramadan, the first
day of Shawwal, is Eid, right?
How do we make? Well, the
begins after on the day of the
first day of Shawwal and it
ends after the salah of Eid.
After the Eid salah has been
made. So once the imam finishes
that's the end of a Right? So
in in you know time. It's five
days. Specific and on the day
of it's just one which is you
make and that's it after that.
Alright. We make general all
the way until the imam is
finished with salah. And then
we are done with tekbir. This
is the sun of the prophet with
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
narration mentioning the way
that the prophet made doesn't
exist. what we have in the
Quran is a general command to
make taqbir. Hajj, a general
command to make taqbir. How the
prophet made taqbir. We don't
have an authentic narration.
Mentioning that. Ibn mentions
this week narration and it's
the least week from amongst
[Arabic recitation]
says and this is what many
people do. We have another
wording that is most common. I
don't know. this is this
wording is most common
everywhere I've been basically.
[Arabic recitation]
that Ibn Ibn Ibn Abbas and
Jabber Ibn Abdullah used to
make their taqbir. So, three
tekbir. to and both of them are
correct and good
[Silence]
seen this before. The masjid I
went to when I was a kid in
Indiana. I they probably still
do this. They pass out the
paper and you pick up a paper
and you read along. You know
and it's a long paper of
you know law. It's whole thing.
None of this is authentically
narrated from the prophet if a
[Arabic recitation]
that's enough. If they say
nothing else, they have, done
what the Quran has commanded,
they've done what the prophet
used to do. However, this way
that we mention or the next way
that we mention or the way that
he mentions, all of that is
acceptable and all of that
falls within the generality of
the command of making Taqbir.
of making taqbir after the
during the days of
Next chapters that we're going
to be speaking about are going
to be discussing what the
prophet would say and his
mannerisms with regards to
eating. How he would eat, how
he would drink, and so forth.
It's a very important chapter.
We spend a lot of our lives
eating, right? We spend a lot
of our time drinking and it's a
very easy sunnah to to fulfill.
You know, as you're eating, you
do it the way that the prophet
did. You have to eat anyways.
You turn this eating into, you
turn it into a worship of
Allah. It's of the beauty of
Islam and the you know, the
range of opportunity that is
allotted to the Muslim and his
worship of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. So, next week
inshallah, we will be
discussing
the etiquettes of eating, the
etiquettes of drinking, what a
person should say, how a person
should eat, and so on and so
forth. It's an exciting
chapter. After this, we will
get into
the etiquettes of sneezing,
seeking permission to enter
knocking on doors, things like
that. After that, we will get
into a Salem. The etiquettes on
that. and so forth. these
are very important chapters.
Also, after about a month,
we'll be discussing the prophet
etiquettes in travel and so for
So, that is enough for tonight.
Allah